[Music]
hey you guys it's time once again for
the matinee show this is matinee 73 or
something like that yeah right towards
the grave actually that's rape we did
see a Netflix series and two movies in
the theater so let's get right into it
the first one we're gonna talk about is
the Netflix original series lock and key
yeah now probably most people know this
but this is an adaptation of the very
wildly popular graphic novel series that
ran from 2000 I believe 2003 to 2008
written by Joe Hill you know who's
Stephen Kings kid but he's also like a
very well-known now the funny thing
about this show was that this is like
this poor show it or this poor graphic
novel series I guess because the graphic
novel series was so popular this thing
has been they've done like adaptions of
this like I went all the way back to
2011 now originally they were gonna
adapt as a TV series for Fox they went
ahead they cast the whole [ __ ] thing
they spent all his money on they made a
pilot and then Fox looked at it decided
now we don't really want to option that
they did however like show the the pilot
at Comic Con I think back in 2014 or
something like that with the hopes that
like another production company would
pick it up so then it starts going into
development again in 2016 and in 2017
Hulu comes along and says hey yeah make
us a pilot to like a different one and
maybe we'll pick it up so another pilot
was made and Hulu decided they didn't
want it either yeah so finally finally
in 2018 Netflix said okay well we want
to do an adaptation and we will order a
season however we want to start all over
again so pretty much everybody that was
cast in the original pilot none of the
people are there except for the little
kid that plays Bodie who is the same kid
he played Georgie and it
our button off yeah that was him and so
he was I believe he's the only one
remaining from the original cast from
this poor show which has taken such a
circuitous route to actually becoming a
series so how did it turn out not too
bad um I will say that I'm not um I
haven't read the original graphic novel
series although I did read like a very
complicated like synopsis of it like
where the story goes everything is very
long I mean there's like a lot of
episodes so I do know that some people
have been complaining because it does
seem like this series which is ten
episodes it downplays the horror element
a bit in favor of more like relationship
drama which it seems like the the
graphic novel series had that too like
you know it has the same like teenage
characters and the little kid character
and everything like that and a lot of it
revolves around them
but it seems like the original series or
the original book series was a lot more
I mean the town in the books was called
Lovecraft Massachusetts because it was
supposed to be like a demonic you know
thing and they went more into like the
history of where the demons came from
why the demons around the well like why
they were behind the you know that Omega
door or whatever and all that other
stuff so this this series and you know I
don't know if it's going to get another
season or not I assume it probably will
because I think it you know is it's
doing fairly well but maybe they'll get
more into that this one pretty much
sticks to like the middle portion of the
book series whereas it's just like this
family the dad gets murdered by he's a
guidance counselor I think and he gets
murdered by um one of his students who's
like disturbed and the rest of the
family moves out to his like ancestral
mansion in this town in Massachusetts
which the name of it in the series has
been changed to matheson so I guess
they're imagining that now it's more
like a Richard Matheson story than a
Lovecraft story which you know fair
enough and so they moved there and they
soon
to discover that this house is full of
like all these keys that do like really
cool magical [ __ ] like you know one of
them you can stick it in the back of
your head and it like shows you can go
inside your own head and like walk
around in your brain and stuff or all
your thoughts or whatever there's one
that can take you anywhere in the world
like if you stick into the door and like
you know you you picture somewhere and
you can go there so there you know
there's there's all these really cool
things and so there's kind of this other
story where you know the demon is trying
to get the kid to find keys for her and
then it ties in with the dad and the
dad's murder and [ __ ] that happened like
before and everything so I feel like I
don't know like I feel like the balance
was a little too far into the teenage
relationship drama cuz a lot goes into
you know the two teenage kids Tyler and
Kinsey who you know that I'm going to
high school and dealing with their dad's
death and you know helping little Bodie
like find the keys and everything like
that
I think they leaned into that a little
too hard there are like some really cool
like I really love the concept of this
and I really love you know and and I
think it's intriguing like where they
could go with it I would love to see
like a second season where they went
back and like talked about the you know
the ancestors of the Locke family and
like how the demons got there and all
cuz I know how they did because I looked
at the because I read about the books
but um so I don't know if they're gonna
do that or not but I definitely feel
like they need to amp up the horror and
fantasy thank Banta see factor as
opposed to like the relationship yeah
she need relationship drama gashing you
need to care about the characters stuff
what she do but I kind of wish that they
would make it a bit darker I you know I
see what they're going for it's like yes
stranger things is very successful a
series of unfortunate events is very
successful this so this gives me a vibe
like that and also kind of like a little
bit of house with the clock in its walls
it gave me a little bit of that kind of
vibe to where it's just kind of like
this magical realism but not too dark I
feel like this could benefit from going
darker
um so I kind of hope they do that I did
really like it and it kept me like
interested until they handed everything
but I feel like it's a little too tame
considering this source material even
though like I said I can see why they're
doing that because you know they're
there other shows like that are really
successful this is it's a little bit
like haunting a pillow house - that's
obviously a lot more adult oriented and
a lot darker this is like sort of like a
kid version of that you know what I mean
so it's not it's not bad it's like I I
really liked it and I really thought
that the concept is really cool the set
design is cool like the inside of key
house I believe that whole entire thing
is a set the inside at least and they
did a phenomenal job on that is
beautiful looking and I loved like all
the keys and finding the keys and like
finding out what they did and [ __ ] like
that I just they need more of that and
less of like the teen drama that's all
I'm saying but overall I think it's a
pretty good show you know well he wasn't
really big so it won't violated all
kinds of rules real early so I just what
didn't you like about it boring
first of all slow nothing really
happened to it that Payton nothing
happened to them in the first 20 minutes
to pique my interest I just didn't think
it was interesting yeah well you know
yeah like I said love T drama yes they
said I you know I I did it's not made
for me yeah we're in an era where they
move me they make things for people like
okay this is for women and it's for this
age group or this is for men and it's
for this age nothing is like yeah this
is way it out here yeah everything seems
to be made for a certain oh an
intersectional demographic or something
and you know white 50 year old male no
you know [ __ ] well boring well like I
said I didn't find it boring but I do
feel like they since the graphic novel
series was a lot more horror oriented
and a lot more love crap
that's how we I wish that they had gone
a little bit more that's right that's
not what we got when we're doing a movie
review we're talking about what they
gave us yeah I did like it but I can see
how but but I can see how that criticism
could be made yeah especially after I've
read about the graphic novel series and
the story behind that and you know what
happened in all of that stuff so it is
much dark even stranger things you know
for me it was a little more watchable
because it was set in a time period in
which I lived in a head of kind of a
[ __ ] cool Gestalt and kind of a
nostalgic wanting a nostalgic quality to
it you know I mean I'm just kind of
amazed how well they reproduced [ __ ]
the mentality of the 80s and way things
looked I mean so that was a certain draw
but this is okay this is generic generic
and bland it is a little yeah like I
said they considering the how cool the
concept is they could have done more
with it and like I said I kind of hope
that they do that if they can once you
have like a generic and kind of bland
corporate feel to something and not much
happens out of the ordinary you check
out early you don't care about the story
yeah you know I mean we live in another
era we don't live in the in the
slow-burn era anymore and I think I
think you have to be in certain moods to
watch movies in series and most people
are not most people just randomly have
to watch a movie or they start watching
they're not really they may not be in
that mood I don't know it's hard it's
hard to say I just thought it was bland
and corporate yeah and you know I I kind
of agree like I said I liked it but I
agree with that assessment I just to me
it seemed like the concept is so cool
the source material is so cool they
could have done a little bit more with
it like they could have adjusted the
balance more should have been in it
maybe like an exciting story well no
they should have gone like a much darker
dragon yeah another was exciting you
know there was it was some cool [ __ ] in
there then like especially like at the
end like in the last episode like they
actually finally got kind of busted out
with the demons and everything like that
and I was like they should have had more
of that like throughout you know what I
mean there was like some flashes of like
really cool dark [ __ ] in there but it's
like I don't it wasn't quite enough it
seemed like it
yeah more geared if it seemed more
geared toward a younger audience alight
like a series of unfortunate events or
something like that it gave me that kind
of you have to give me something early
on in that first ten minutes to give me
any incentive to hook me give me a
sentence to consider continue watching
it and just the nature of the story
that's being told and the characters and
it's just I don't care yeah well yeah
man like I love the first three or four
seasons of the [ __ ] walk-in dead I was
admittedly in that yeah I was I wanted
it you know what's the neck what's gonna
happen next episode I wasn't like that
with this I didn't care
yeah that's uh yeah so like I said I'm
kind of hoping if it gets a second
season at all kind of take some of the
criticisms that's been getting on board
and sort of go more in the direction of
the graphic novel and less in the
direction of more family-friendly kind
of fun I don't know if I call it family
friendly but it's definitely geared
toward a younger audience and I think
they should kind of more go at it don't
go with more haunting of Hillhouse
direction I mean you don't I mean she
was bored huh this movie this this
series of second boring yeah no I
thought you said party yes so you know
check it out if it sounds like your kind
of thing it's like I said it's not as
good as I hear the graphic novel series
was but you know let's see what your
you
for the second movie we actually went to
the theater finally and saw DC's birds
of prey yeah boy I tell you what I
thought this [ __ ] was gonna suck I
really did I thought this is gonna be
some kind of man bashing ultra walk
faster [ __ ] because the way the way
they the way they sold this thing is it
was gonna be a movie about misogyny so
every [ __ ] every [ __ ] guy out there
went oh here we go man you're better
title oh here we go it this is gonna be
some anti man [ __ ] but then when I watch
it is pretty entertaining and it wasn't
that well clearly it was got fake look
yet I mean please don't use that word it
was fake work it was the same kind of
[ __ ] it was the same kind of [ __ ] you
two the same kind of movies get in the
90s this is what anything new well yeah
that's what I mean this was actually
it's funny because um I didn't have a
lot of like I didn't see Suicide Squad I
know a lot of people like kind of [ __ ]
on that because it wasn't just because I
you know thought it was gonna suck or
anything it's just I'm not super into
superhero movies so it's not like I'll
go see them and like sometimes I enjoy
them even the Marvel what Marvel and
stuff but it's never anything that I'm
just like oh I gotta go out and see that
you know what I mean so I just never got
around to seeing Suicide Squad but I did
hear later on you know that pretty much
it's pretty much universally like
everyone [ __ ] on it so when this came
out and I saw the previews I'm like oh
no it's kind of dumb and I look like
John and I thought you know I was like
man Suicide Squad got really [ __ ] on
like over the years so it's like maybe
that won't really be any good but then
it seemed like I don't know like I I
wasn't all that jazzed about seeing it
but then I just started kind of hearing
through the grapevine that they're like
hey this may be actually pretty good and
so I was like so Tom's like well maybe
we should go see it and I was like yeah
I guess so I wasn't like super jazzed
belty cuz like I said it's you know it's
not really my type of movie but then
when we went to see it I was like it was
actually a [ __ ] hell of a lot of fun
yeah it's a fun [ __ ] movie yeah it's
not a serious movie it did the
problem okay what they did was is it
kind of took kind of had the tone of the
old Liana Leonardo DiCaprio wasn't
Claire Danes was that uh the Romans you
battle urban yeah it kind of had that
tone mixed with I don't know John wick
and maybe like I think it was the same
stunt coordinator yeah and like maybe
mixed in with a little bit of I don't
know like Tank Girl yeah and I liked it
is it was funny and it kind of had a
tone very similar to Shazam I love
Shazam yeah it actually really it
reminded me of it it's a completely
different movie than Shazam yeah but Sam
had a Power Rangers element to it yeah
because the original series had a damn
Power Rangers element there's a little
more closer to the Romeo and Juliet the
basil what's his name really John loved
that movie yeah I love that I love that
movie but it had kind of like that kind
of edit and I was kind of pissed because
I was looking forward to [ __ ] bagging
on this movie but I can't bag on it it
was pretty good I liked it that's what I
mean it was actually like I said I
wasn't uh you know I I don't look
forward to like [ __ ] on movies or
anything like that it's like sometimes
I'm looking forward to one sometimes I'm
just like okay we'll see how this one
goes yeah this was one where like I said
I'd seen the trailers and I was kind of
like I don't know if that's for me but
then when we saw it I was kind of like I
actually really liked it I think I liked
it as much as I like Shazam quite a bit
it's not doing well at the box office
alright Sonic is kicking its ass but I
looked at all the data and looked at
what the problem and this is this is
what this is how they [ __ ] this movie up
first of all the [ __ ] title it has a
ridiculous [ __ ] title the real title
is birds of prey the Fantana fantabulous
it's a baby yeah that is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
piss poor [ __ ] title it should have
just been called Harley Quinn and the
birds of prey
that's debt well because the birds of
prey aren't really in it until the very
[ __ ] yeah and considering I mean yeah
he's gonna see Harley Quinn the
characters the
individual birds of prey like black
canary and hunters and all them are in
it like individually but they don't
really get together until like the last
15 or 20 minutes of the movie second
problems ahead it had shitty trailers
that the trailers that you saw don't
illustrate way that movie is the second
trailer was bet a little bit bad about
two different trailers and the first one
I was like yeah that looks [ __ ] fire
that [ __ ] the second one was
like well that looks better but it still
doesn't look like that kid who ever made
those trailers needs to be fired
alright the third one that's the third
thing about it is that the way they
handled the [ __ ] advertising campaign
and where they went on little talk shows
a [ __ ] like that I mean the head obi-wan
Kenobi what's that [ __ ] day I like
the guy he's saying this is a movie
about misogyny every [ __ ] every
[ __ ] male potential fan is like oh
shits gonna be crece yeah that's gonna
be preachy so you lost a lot of the male
audience alright and then it's rated R
that's another [ __ ] problem this
should have been PG there's no reason
why this just it's not worth it I'd take
a couple [ __ ] out of there and maybe
get rid of that a grenade explosion and
make this PG and you get a lot of more
asses in the seats it's funny because no
reason um I can't remember if it was the
New York Times or Sony like one of the
big you know papers that had there that
have reviewed this they said pretty they
really liked it too but they said pretty
much the exact thing the thing that you
said there that this doesn't really need
to be it's like yes there's like yes
someone like hazard granadan explodes
and you know blows part yes there's
black mask and he does like cut people's
faces off although you know they don't
really show that they just kind of show
like the lídia the lead up in the
aftermath you know people's legs get
broken and [ __ ] like that but it's like
not super super graphic yeah it's mostly
there's yeah there's like a lot of
swearing stuff like that so yeah I can
see how if they could just they probably
could just trim like oh yeah and what
really being pg-13 what really killed
this movie is the advertising campaign
they sold it as a woke movie for females
females didn't go to it
alright you looked at the data at the at
the audience is like 60 70 percent
that's who's going to see it all right
but there should have been more males
and there should have been the kids for
the PG think it would have been much
more successful if you had a positive
advertising campaign because the movie
is not [ __ ] preachy and [ __ ] and
and it's not preachy not at all it's
very upbeat and a lot of fun it's
nothing there's nothing serious it's
like Harley Quinn's character I think
the reason it's a comedy action
adventure comedy i mean you know margot
robbie like you know she wanted to
produce this movie i think because she
really likes playing Harley Quinn and
she was upset that like Suicide Squad
hadn't done that well if she thought the
character had been hard done by by that
movie so she you know basically said I
want to play them play it again and it's
like so she's been like trying to get
this developed for a long time and I
mean the thing about it is that yes
Harley Quinn is a psychotic be you know
what I mean she's an antihero for sure
but the way that it's approached in this
movie she doesn't kill anybody though
not really she hurts some people but
most of them deserve it to me when she
fights the cops she uses non-lethal
weapons yeah she yeah I guess she didn't
kill some bad guys but they were trying
to kill her
that's what I suggest a viable homicide
yeah she doesn't murder anybody
not in cold blood no no now she does
some shitty things but she did some [ __ ]
he thinks - some bad guys
yeah well I mean she did a shitty thing
to that kid - but you know oh yeah but
she didn't really have much of a choice
that's true but she is an antihero ya
know another thing that might be wrong
with the movie is that a lot of people
said they didn't like the costumes that
she wore I didn't have a big problem
with them either I thought they were
okay but somebody who's really into this
character who makes videos and [ __ ]
about DC Comics said that really what
sells that character is kind of a punk
rock look and they showed he showed old
drawings of her throughout her comic
book you know history of this character
and and and once I saw kind of a more
punk-rock version so that characters
like yeah that probably would have sold
more tickets yeah if she had a marvel
punk rock gestalt I did like her look in
yeah is okay it's but it looks tame
compared yeah to some of the stuff that
she wore in the comic books and I think
the trailers would have been more
effective if it was had her in the kind
of a punk rock
she almost kind of looked a little bit
like Catwoman at certain times yeah you
know I mean a Harlequin version of
Catwoman and I think that would have
sold a lot probably a lot better and
Amanda's those trailers were terrible
for this and that the advertising
campaign and the title I've seen that
happen a lot though does sometimes we'll
see a trailer because we go to the
movies a lot so we see a lot of trailers
and like sometimes I'll see a trailer
and go wow that looks like the stupidest
movies yeah there you go there you go
see it you're like yeah it was the
average I don't trust any trailer
anymore
it is the advertising campaign I think
that's kind of hurting this movie and
the title I do feel like though that
maybe like the better reviews it gets
like I could I could totally see how
some people might not like this movie
like for one it's very frenetic it's
very frenetically paced it jumps back
and forth a lot it's very like chaotic
um you know what I mean so but that's
kind of like in fitting with her
character cuz she'll be like go on about
something and be like oh wait I forgot
to tell you this we have to go back to a
week ago and then there's like a long
segment like that so you know I can see
how could that might annoy some people
or anything but I feel like anybody that
is into Harlequins character or knows
about the movie portrayal of that
character I don't think they would be
bothered by that I just think this is
like it was a super fun it was super
colorful um the action scenes were
amazing like the way they shot them like
there was enough of them though there
was their thing it should have been a
couple more like the one in the
warehouse where she was fighting the
[ __ ] bikers I love it for those
bikers with their [ __ ] equipment what
they were wearing it yeah it looked
really good the fight scene was good
then the cocaine blew up in the air and
they were all that [ __ ] was really good
I'm telling you what's hurt in this
movie was the title the ad campaign and
the ad campaign including the trailers I
was expecting a real preachy con a man
he
[ __ ] third-wave wolf s intersection
no it's not really what it was it was
actually kind of like an old-school
1960s Russ Meyer flicks like faster
pussycat kill kill kill
but updated a lot it's it's not new this
is a throwback movie really it is kind
of it's a throat it's a good old
fashioned throwback action adventure
comedy i mean female i said you do get
the thing where you know at the end they
all start to work together but it's not
so much they all start to work together
because they all have a common goal yeah
you know what I mean they're trying to
take down you know black masks you and
McGregor you and you could nitpick and
say well there's no men good guys all
men are bad guys well she's dealing with
the criminal underworld well and most of
the women are bad guys
yeah no women are better but yes you can
some people were really trying to read
into this movie to make it woke her than
it was which is getting them a reason
not to go I thought that I think the
movies asleep or I think over time
people might like this one a little bit
so - I think it's gonna pick up I mean I
feel like probably Suicide Squad I feel
like people hate it
even now more now than they did when I
remember she found it I haven't seen it
either so I'm not commenting saying if
that movie wasn't as bad as they said it
was maybe not but like I said it's we've
had a few years to reflect on that and I
still hear people talking about how bad
it was like I said I don't know if it
was bad or not I didn't see it
but so I feel like maybe that'll happen
with this one like maybe you know
because of the trailers because of the
title because of other things it was
like people were like on or because of
the lingering stench of Suicide Squad
and people like I don't really want to
see that but maybe the fact that it's
getting like pretty decent reviews and
people seem to be enjoying it yeah and I
believe those audience reviews well I
mean I've read a lot of like I read a
lot of you know like professional
reviews and stuff - and like 80 to 90%
of them like really really liked them
yeah
so a lot of times they're shields but I
kind of agree with what I saw that they
said well I don't think you know they're
saying the same [ __ ] that we said yeah
they had some of the same criticisms
about like how it was marketed and like
you know probably
probably it shouldn't have been an R you
know they would have got a wider
audience you know cuz all they would
have to do was take a cup they could say
they could save this they wait a couple
months and around Chris's trying to do
what they did with Deadpool yeah I think
you know the pg-13 13 version of it you
come out with a pg-13 version of this
with a different title and a slightly
different advertising campaign for
Christmas and you they probably make
more money on this again it's actually
kind of getting nuts a unjustifiably
[ __ ] chick and I think that's just my
opinion I mean yeah me too and like I
said I wasn't really expecting to say
that I was expecting this to be like an
okay movie but I actually had a lot more
fun yeah than I thought I thought it was
a blast I was gonna say before like when
you were talking about fight scenes I
was like I think my best my favorite
fight scene was when they was when she
was with she was on the roller skates
and like Hunters on the motorcycle they
were like jumping back and forth into
the car and [ __ ] like that one thing
about like I said I think the same stunt
person that worked on are the same stunt
coordinator that worked on John wick I
think and like worked on this movie and
you can tell because the fight scenes
look very realistic it's like in a way
that there's some things that obviously
you know like a normal person couldn't
really do and stuff like that but the
way that it shot doesn't look like all
CGI it it doesn't look like Marvel you
know super hero fights everybody's
flying around that little tennis balls
or anything like that it really looked
like actual people doing acrobatic [ __ ]
and fighting yeah and it was staged
really well so you could like tell what
was going on it's like it wasn't like it
was kind of quickly edited but not so
quickly that you grew tell what was
happening the Edit was very much that
old Romeo Juliet I liked it very yeah
fast paced good cuts close-ups on people
and then like graphics that pop up out
with their names who they were and then
there was there was a voiceover she'd
voiceover stuff which is usually
terrible but it worked in this in this
yeah it's kind of more in line with her
character and it has a goofy context it
jumps around a little bit but it is fast
paced this shot there's flashbacks and
stuff in it it's fast paced it's trying
to give you non-stop non-stop action and
it only slows down a couple times enough
for very long really it was it was a
good movie yeah it pretty
keep Sangha I mean some of my favorite
[ __ ] in this one of my favorite jokes
and this was just like a total throwaway
gag about Frida Kahlo which is like that
[ __ ] cracked me up so I was like I
saw that [ __ ] yeah the whole [ __ ] of
buying the egg salad yeah I was gonna
say the whole [ __ ] about the breakfast
sandwich isn't she like stuffs it down
her shirt she's like friend to down the
street with her [ __ ] breakfast
sandwich cuz I was like I feel that yeah
perfect breakfast sandwich thing yeah
also only criticism I could probably
make was I was gonna say to her
you and McGregor was [ __ ] great at
this he just he decided he's like you
know what I'm just gonna chew all the
scenery and yeah yeah yeah and it
totally worked
he was just like totally over the top
and foppish and he was like and he was
hilarious yeah just like [ __ ] he lead
right into it it kind of place kind of
like this evil kind of like pansexual
[ __ ] Club owner who's just a [ __ ]
total psychopath yeah he's just like so
and like masks you don't see him put it
on till the very end some people
criticize the movie for that but I don't
think he's a very famous DC character
anyway that's what I mean they just
needed an antagonist for the right movie
like yeah and don't this is not this is
not a movie to be taken seriously and
overanalyze it was as fun as Shazam like
I said yeah only like I said the only
thing I could ding it for it needed more
Huntress mary elizabeth winstead was so
[ __ ] funny in this because she was
just like she was so deadpan because she
had like social anxiety and stuff and
you could tell like she and like the
whole [ __ ] with her like you know she's
going around killer and he's like
everybody's call her the cross because
she's like god dammit you know because
she's trying to get people to know her
Huntress and she's like really unless
she's like socially anxious and doesn't
know how to like interact with people
let's do it it's like really really
funny
so it kind of like needed more of her I
feel like but that's kind of the only
it's not and of course you know there's
celica of a girl power angle but it's
kind of stuff deprecating because they
fail a lot too it's just funny you know
it's that's what I was saying it's just
kind of like a fake book movie it's it's
just a comedy movie yeah don't take the
[ __ ] so see that's what I mean yeah I
didn't take it very seriously I just
thought it was like a lot of fun and now
I might have to actually go back and
watch suicide I would
mine unless everybody tells me no don't
do it I actually would not wouldn't mind
owning this and on blu-ray like like
I've said before my words stand I don't
really like Marvel too much I think
Marvel is very kind of sterile and
corporate and like yeah they're good but
I don't they're not memorable yeah you
can get done with it you like what
happened you know I mean I barely
remember all the DC stuff I've seen kind
of made an impression on me a little bit
more than I didn't like Batman vs
Superman that much I had it I thought it
was kind of you know I think I fell
asleep
it was long the longer version of it
made a little more sense that I have to
go see it again I don't once
I feel like DC when they try to do
something more serious it always comes
across as kind of boring it's like don't
try to be Marvel Marvel already has that
like epic we're very serious superhero
do goofy [ __ ] right even if it's even if
it fails not like Aquaman was awesome it
was kind of like the old Flash Gordon
which I love the EDS I mean it was
lovely Flash Gordon the 1980 Flash
Gordon is one of my favorite movies and
it looks great on blu-ray if you guys
haven't seen I got a plug that movie
watch that [ __ ] on blu-ray out on modern
[ __ ] that's what it was like when we
saw it in the theaters kids it's [ __ ]
really [ __ ] epic it looks like [ __ ]
on VHS and DVD but I love [ __ ]
Aquaman I didn't see I didn't see Wonder
Woman but everybody says it's great we
gotta see that
Shazam I loved it yeah I think we saw
that like three or four - yeah the
Harley Quinn a movie I liked it yeah
what else did we see that was from DC
that I liked [ __ ] man I can t remember
now I think that might be it yeah but I
gotta see uh I gotta see Wonder Woman
yeah I've like I've heard really good
things about that and like pretty much
every review of the Harley Quinn me oh
well Joker's DC yeah that's true you
know sex although I don't even like
think of this now the shame it's not the
same it's not the same style no but
every like every review I've seen if
like the Harley Quinn movie is putting
it up there they said you know it's not
quite as good as like Wonder Woman but
they said it's up there with like Shazam
and like all the other all their other
good ones so do you know I feel like DC
needs to come up with a new bed
and a new Superman something that can
[ __ ] do we really need another Batman
and another Superman though well you
like they've made so many well I think
they need to make I think they need to
make a Batman that fits with that
billion dollar Joker in that style I
guess and it's happening in the
seventies but I don't know it's it's
just a nice guy it's kind of like you
know Marvel it's like do we really need
more spider-man movies not know [ __ ]
against into the spider-verse cuz that
was rad but it's like they've made so
many they've rebooted them they've been
and then especially like Batman and
Superman it's like not only have they
had like 50 bajillion million movies but
they've also had like TV series and
they've also like all these other
offshoots and I feel like I just feel
like they should go more into like their
lesser known characters because it's
like you really need another [ __ ]
Batman movie I was like I liked a lot of
the Batman movies but I just feel like
we don't need another one for me
Tobey Maguire is always gonna be [ __ ]
spider-man yeah and Christopher Reeves
is always gonna be Superman well yeah
it's hardly that you have to get the
right people to play these roles and
they got to be traditional or it's just
not that [ __ ] character you know I
mean Superman's gotta be just
americanist [ __ ] you know the mean just
like the he's got to be a you know the
mean he's got to be a stereotypical
almost iconic American superhero and you
know you need a certain kind of person
for that something that doesn't have any
back at baggage that was the thing about
damn you know Reeves Reef showed up he
was already you know had such a good
reputation he with the public he was in
romance movies and [ __ ] like that you
know so he was very slim
he was wholesome he has to be and that's
what Superman was Superman was [ __ ]
wholesome yeah you know so you have to
find an actor that can pull that off do
that it's hard to find a Hollywood today
well I'm just saying that you know the
both DC and Marvel have such rich
catalogs yeah of like all these
different characters and stuff like that
that I I just feel like it'd be cool
that's why I'm kind of glad to see like
a Harley Quinn movie to see like other
ones that are like with other I mean I
know if she's not that much lesser-known
I guess
but I would rather see that than another
Batman movie or another Superman movie
or another I don't think this is gonna
do well enough at the box office to get
it uh to get a sequel I mean I hope it
does but it doesn't just I would totally
watch a movie about the Huntress though
just saying I think she could carry
around movie you'd have to break you did
if you brought if you bought brought
Harley Quinn back you'd have to bring
back like a punk-rock Harley Quinn yeah
cuz I tell you what she was great in
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood and she
gets great in this I thought she was
great in this she really embodied
Garrett's role she can do the character
Margot Robbie is a really like she is a
really uh she can do like a lot of
diverse roles that I was pretty cool I
think that one guy's saying that a punk
rock version of it like the comic books
I think would be better I think they
would bring any more people if they
bring it back I hope they take it more
in that direction yeah I guess they
could yeah I mean like I said since this
one went a little more non-traditional
or away from her comic book counterpart
a little bit or the red and black outfit
yeah with the little man that would work
good - yeah you know I mean just but I
think I think that I think the movie
actually was good yeah that's very good
yeah I had a good time with it yeah
nothing wrong with it at all like I said
really funny like you know just a fun
time
yeah just like really colorful like a
really action-packed you know a lot of
the humor was like really I'm gonna buy
it on blu-ray yeah you know I mean
that's quite a recommendation you guys
yeah
did you guys like it yeah I didn't
either I like I said I was expecting it
to be like all right but I actually had
to I thought it was a blast yeah you
know so see you see what you guys think
you
all right third movie we saw this week
in the theater this is the horror movie
the lodge now this actually I believe it
premiered at a film festival early last
year and it was supposed to actually
come out in November of this year but it
got put pushed back for whatever reason
so we've recently just thought I had
somebody like messaged me earlier today
like before we recorded this going hey
how are you guys seeing that I'm like um
it's just playing at the regular ole AMC
theater I don't know where you guys live
but okay it played at the theater here
so maybe it's not getting a wide release
I don't know um cuz usually when I don't
know we don't usually get like a lot of
more indie movies either but I feel like
AMC is trying to do a little bit better
because many movie yeah okay isn't it
because now they have AMC artisan films
and all that other kind of stuff
now this was directed by a Veronica
Franz and Severin Fiamma who are
Austrian now the Hammer horror film they
were one of the producers yeah some of
you might be familiar with those two
names because they did the Austrian film
good night mommy which was it almost has
like a similar setup to this one in the
sense of like isolation and the fact
that there being two kids and like you
not really sure what's going on and I
will say that if you liked goodnight mom
mommy you will probably like this one as
well somatically they're very similar
although kind of in practice they come
out very different but the story is that
there's this there's this guy and he has
two kids named Aiden and Mia and he him
and his wife who was played by Alicia
Silverstone although she's not in it
very much like only a few minutes like
at the beginning he they're kind of
separated and he decides that he's gonna
ask her to finalize the divorce because
he wants to marry his much younger
girlfriend which causes the mom of the
two kids to commit suicide now
interestingly the dad's girlfriend
apparently they've met I think he was a
journalist and he worked on a book about
her because she was the only survivor of
a cult like it was kind of like it was
like a real hardcore Catholic called
but in practice it was kind of like that
like the heavens like the Heaven's Gate
cult where they like all decided they
were gonna kill themselves and like go
go to have go to heaven or whatever so
she was like a little girl when that
happened and she was the one that was
left alive like to document it and like
show the world and everything like that
spread the teachings to spread the
teachings and yeah you know show
everybody their sacrifice or whatever so
the kids you know six months later it's
almost Christmas time and the dad says
it's for their free hold on yeah yes you
know and he says this is just the setup
okay um you know the dad says to the
kids you know we're gonna go up to you
know the lodge you know which is kind of
this remote like you know place out and
[ __ ] Milano where like I think it's
in Massachusetts or New England
somewhere and we're gonna go up there
for Christmas
oh and my new girlfriend it's kind of
like it's all been six months like since
the kid's mom died now the kids probably
understandably um kind of blame this
woman there you know soon-to-be
stepmother for the death of their mother
you know and you can kind of see why
they do so they're like not happy about
this but it all ends up you know they
all end up going up there it comes to
pass that the two kids and the and the
woman whose name is Grace are left there
alone while he has to go back to the
city for a few days to do some work yeah
and [ __ ] gets weird from there yeah all
right this one Jenny loved it I did yeah
I had I had a lot of differences with it
for me it was just it just seemed just
insufferably boring very slow and things
do happen but they just happen kind of
late for me and and it's just you know I
I didn't like it that that's all I can
really say about it I mean ya know it'll
spoil too much yeah I don't really want
to give anything away because this is
one of those stories very much it's like
I said if you saw a good night mommy
this is a similar setup and it's like a
similar like I said it's you know cuz
that one was like two kids and then
their mom came back from the hospital
with bandages all over her face and they
became convinced that she was not their
mom
anymore like she was an impostor and you
weren't really sure if they were right
or if you know what I mean so there was
that kind of whole ambiguity so this has
a similar kind of vibe to it where
you're not like when all this weird [ __ ]
starts happening in the house you know
there's like a snowstorm and like the
power goes out and all this other kind
of stuff in kind of cabin fever sets in
and so you're not really sure what
exactly is going on until like later on
they do resolve it um you know so they
don't like leave it ambiguous or
anything like that they do they do tell
you what's going on but for a long time
you're not entirely sure and I actually
really really liked that this movie also
gave me a real strong hereditary vibe
even down to like the dollhouse type of
thing because they have like a you know
a dollhouse kind of motif going on in
there - I didn't like it as much as I
like to read Atari but if you liked
hereditary and if you like - goodnight
mommy you will probably like this as
well as Tom said now this is definitely
only recommended for people who like you
know art house horror a24 type stuff
slow burn because it's very you know
it's very slow it's very atmospheric
most of it is concerned with you know
these kind of long things like trying to
like have this you know this feeling of
like claustrophobia or isolation and
where you're not really sure what
reality is so some people might find
that a little you know a little tedious
or anything like that I really got into
it and I thought it was like really
creepy and like really unsettling but I
can see how somebody might not think
that you know what I mean but it's
interesting to me that like I said I
didn't like it as much as hereditary but
this is definitely one that I want to
watch again because the resolution of it
makes me want to go back and see like
what I miss much like hereditary cuz
like if you if you didn't know like when
you figure out like what happens it then
and then you go back and watch it again
and all through the movie there's like
all kind of [ __ ] clues that you don't
see the first time because you don't
know what's gonna I think what happened
I didn't like
no but I'm just saying I liked midsummer
yeah but I know you're talking about I
don't know if there's anything there
worth seeing it again guy I mean I just
I thought it was kind of a simple well
I'm talking about me I'm talking about
you I don't think you're gonna find
anything there that's what I'm thinking
no I'm just interested to see the lead
up to like I don't want to spoil
anything I'm just saying I want to see
because I did notice like when I thought
about it cuz this is a movie that I was
that I was thinking about like much many
hours after I saw it and I was thinking
about little details that I had noticed
like in the beginning that seemed like
they didn't mean anything but then later
on I was like oh okay I said what you
know what I mean so I I would really
like to like see this again to see like
pick out all the [ __ ] that I missed cuz
I like doing that like I said that's
what I do with hereditary and there's
that movie is like a whole different
experience like the second time you
watch it because there's all kind of
[ __ ] in there that you don't notice the
first time because you don't know like
what the outcomes gonna be but once you
know what the outcome is and you go back
and watch it you're like holy crap I
miss so much stuff but I feel like this
one might be another one like that
like I said it's you can tell they're
trying to go for like a shining type of
vibe because it's like this this Lodge
and there's like the middle of nowhere
and like someone is create maybe going
crazy maybe not you don't really know
and you don't know like where the line
between reality and insanity is you
don't know if everybody's dreaming you
don't know if everybody's you know what
I mean so I really like that like I said
now if you're into art house horror if
you're into that kind of slow burn type
of [ __ ] you should probably check it out
if you like to Reddit air you'll
probably love it if you like goodnight
mommy you will probably love it if
you're more into like kind of
traditional horror or more like slasher
type of horrid you'll probably hate it
so probably stay away this seems like
it's gonna be another one that's really
divisive but a lot of these arthouse
horror films are oh if you like the
witch you would probably like this as
well kind of a similar it's kind of a
similar vibe to that but you know what I
mean it's I really liked it a lot
Tom hated it it's you know I hate it
here's the he yeah I didn't I didn't
enjoy it I thought it was insufferable
yeah right I think I think you the story
is not very complicated it's a simple
story and I think the store
is actually pretty good but it would
have made her much better like 30
minutes short story I thought that it
was unnecessarily stretched out they
tried to make it very long to try to
give it gravitas and try to set some
kind of a tone but anything was
effective okay I think it should have
just been shorter yeah I mean I could
have got it
I could have made it could it could have
also been a fast-paced horror movie tell
that same story and wouldn't have been
such a tedious experience that that's
for the audience yeah that's what I'm
saying yeah I just thought it's boring
long shots long pant long clothes big
pan backs conversations that don't
really have to be there you know I mean
just stuff like that your again it's
European yeah this gave me oh wait gave
me a hug a zoo so yeah now you know well
these are foreigners making this [ __ ]
but yet that's what it is
yeah Austrian Austrians right now I had
seen their first movie like I'm a good
night mommy which I really I couldn't
really put my finger on it till you said
so the world of course that's a European
movie the [ __ ] take forever not like
here where everything's over into saying
yes over to sex we get that [ __ ] over
with man come on get that [ __ ] over with
now I'm just saying you know it's more
of a an art work than it is a piece of
entertainment well it's an experience
yeah I mean it's and you have to like I
said it's it's just like I mean anybody
that's really into kind of like more
atmospheric horror you have to kind of
go into it with you have to just like
let yourself get into it yeah and not
don't try to fight it don't try to be
like oh I wish it was this that and the
other thing you just have to kind of
like immerse yourself in yeah I had that
first [ __ ] half found that's what I
mean the first half of it which is about
an hour I'm like hurry the [ __ ] up okay
I get the idea
hurry the [ __ ] up what's happening you
know it's just that's the way I felt no
I mean yeah but like I said it's you
know it's just a different way of
approaching this the reason I enjoy
these is because I just kind of let
myself like immerse myself in the
atmosphere and in the characters and
everything like that because I want it
to like
take me somewhere yeah there was nothing
is not even liking you the characters
really well the character nothing about
these characters that side we're
interesting because they're just so
bland if I say something about it it's
gonna I thought I'd better not but the
main the main girl grace Riley Keough I
thought she was [ __ ] great in this
that it's all good acting but I'm
talking with the writing and who the
characters are in the situation I just
thought it was all just very bland very
bland and generic yeah I mean I mean it
could have been any any girl any boy any
what any guy any chick you know I mean
just they were just surgeon Eric so like
I said you know if you're into kind of
more arthouse horror you probably dig it
I know it's um it's one that after it
made the rounds of the festivals like a
lot of people were looking forward to it
so like I said but like I said if you're
if you're like Tom and you don't and you
have to have everything like right now
and you want everything like blowing up
and it's and you want everything to be
over in two seconds then you will
probably just like I like I like I like
I like an American pacing to thinks I
just did everyone has a DD whatever but
yeah so check it out if you're really
into atmospheric style horror if it's
playing in the theater new year or
whatever it'll probably be on shudder
soon anyway
you